Ahmed studying in Candi, Sri Lanka.
Asalamum sir. Wallaykum. Asalam. Is
having bodyguards permissible in Islam?
The question posed is is having
bodyguards permissible? If it's a
requirement and as long as you're not
breaking of the Sharia, then it's
permissible. Even the prophet during
times of trouble, during times of war,
he had Sabas who used to protect him
whether to call them bodyguards or not.
So having bodyguards is permissible. You
know there are many people who are not
on the straight path. Gangsters have
bodyguards. There are people who are
holy against their bodyguards. So if
you're a gangster causing loss to the
people and having bodyguards then that
act of being a gangster itself is wrong.
That act of you doing something haram in
the like you have caused damage to many
people, you have looted many people, you
have caused loss to many people and you
fear somebody will attack you and then
you keep a bodyguard then that act only
is wrong and that bodyguard also if the
Muslim he cannot protect someone who is
a robber he cannot protect. So the two
parts of this answer one is can you have
and can the Muslim be a bodyguard. So,
so if you are for example there are some
dies who may fear that because of dawa
someone may attack them and that was the
case during the prophet and the sabas.
So if then you have bodyguards no
problem or if you are on Quran and
sunnah if you're not doing anything
wrong and then you have bodyguard is
promise it is perfectly promisable. Some
people may say that okay you have of
course you have faith in Allah but Allah
says tie your camel and then trust in
God. You cannot leave your camera and
then trust in God. So having bodyguard
is permissible in Islam. That doesn't
mean you don't trust Allah. But your
main security is Allah subhanaa tala.
The people who will protect you main is
Allah. Whether through the bodyguard or
through other things that's different.
Now regarding a Muslim, can he be a
bodyguard? Can he be a security guard?
Yes. If he's securing a place which is
halal, no problem. If he's securing a
supermarket in which halal goods are
sold, no problem. But can he be a
security officer of a ribba bank? And
the answer is no. Can he be a security
of security officer of a gambling den?
And the answer is no. Because activity
there is haram. It's a gambling den. So
he can't be a security guard of a
gambling den. He cannot be security
guard of alcohol shop. But he can be
security guard of a promises which is
permitted of a supermarket which is
selling halal goods. Similarly, he can
be a bodyguard of a person who is not
causing loss to the amount, not doing
anything haram. He can be a bodyguard of
a businessman who's very rich and he's
earning halal. But he fear that somebody
may attack him, no problem. He can be a
bodyguard of someone who is adai or
someone who a very influential person.
But he cannot be a bodyguard of a
gangster. He cannot be a bodyguard of a
person who's a Rafian, a person who's
called lost to the DMA. So both way as
long as you're on the Quran and Sunnah
and having a bodyguard is no problem at
all. It's permissible.